- [Instructor] In this video,
I want to tackle an entire
AP macroeconomics free
response exercise with you.
Assume that the economy of Country X has
an actual unemployment rate of 7%,
a natural rate of unemployment of 5%,
and an inflation rate of 3%.
Using the numerical values given above,
draw a correctly labeled
graph of the short-run
and long-run Phillips curves.
Label the current short-run
equilibrium as point B.
Plot the numerical values
above on the graph.
So pause this video if
you are inspired to do so,
but I will now work through it.
So remember, Phillips
curves show the relationship
or the theoretical relationship
between the unemployment
rate and the inflation rate.
So I'm gonna do the inflation rate
in the vertical axis which is typical.
And then on the horizontal axis,
I am going to do my unemployment rate.
So this is going to be my
unemployment rate
which is going to be a percentage.
Now we want to graph the short-run
and long-run Phillips curves.
Let's do the long-run first
because we've seen before
the long-run just sets
our unemployment rate
at the natural rate of unemployment,
and it isn't related
to our inflation rate.
It'll just be a vertical line.
And so it'll be a vertical
line at our natural rate
of unemployment which is 5%.
So maybe it looks just like this.
So I could call that our
long-run Phillips curve,
and it's going to be right there at 5%.
And now I have to do the
short-run Phillips curve,
and that will show a relationship
between inflation rate and unemployment.
And just think about what's going on.
If you have low rate of unemployment,
especially if it's below your
natural rate of unemployment,
well then there's a lot
of demand for people.
And so people say, hey,
if you want me to work,
you gotta pay me a little bit more,
and so that could just lead
to a higher inflation rate.
And then if a lot of
people are unemployed,
they might be willing to work for less
or they might have less
money in their pocket
with which to drive up the
prices, and so you will have
this inverse relationship right over here.
So this is the short-run Phillips curve,
which is downward sloping.
And then they say,
label the short-run
equilibrium as point B.
So let's say this is
point B right over here.
And they say the short-run
equilibrium we have
an unemployment rate of 7%
and an inflation rate of 3%.
So our unemployment rate
right over here is 7%,
and our inflation rate
right over here is 3%.
All right, let's do the next section.
Assume that the government of Country X
takes no policy action
to reduce unemployment.
In the long run, which of the
following shift to the right,
shift to the left, or remain the same?
So here they're saying short-run
aggregate supply curve, explain.
So here it's kinda tricky
'cause you might be thinking
they're asking about what you just drew.
But here they're talking
about aggregate supply.
So let me draw a graph to
even help to visualize this.
So if we're talking about aggregate demand
and aggregate supply,
our vertical axis is going
to be our price level,
I'll just call that PL,
and our horizontal axis that
is going to be our real GDP.
So this is real GDP
right over here, G-D-P.
Now you're just going to
have a long-run supply curve
which is vertical.
That's just the full employment
output for our country.
So that's the long-run aggregate supply.
But what about the short-run
aggregate supply curve?
Well, that's going to be upward sloping.
If price levels are low,
people might not be willing
to output a lot, and if
price levels are high,
people will output more.
So our short-run aggregate supply
would look like that.
I'll call that sub one,
since we're gonna think
about how it shifts,
and then aggregate demand
would look something like this.
Let me draw it like that.
And notice, our equilibrium
point right over here,
let me call that aggregate
demand right over here.
Let's call that Y sub one,
and we are at price level sub one.
I drew it to the left
of the long-run aggregate supply curve.
I drew it to the left of
the full employment output
because we are dealing
with a recession here.
Our unemployment rate is higher
than the natural level of unemployment.
So if our actual
unemployment rate is higher
than natural rate of
unemployment, what will happen
to the short-run aggregate supply?
So one way to think about
it, at a given price level,
because there's people out
there looking for a job,
you might be able to get more output.
Or for a given amount of
output, it might cost less
because there's just people out there
competing for that work.
And so you would have your
short-run aggregate supply curve
shift to the right, short-run
aggregate supply sub two.
And then your equilibrium
price level would go down,
price level sub two would go down.
So we could say because
of high unemployment,
that could apply wage pressure.
We could say wages come down
which would shift
the short-run aggregate supply curve
to the right.
And there's a couple of
ways to think about that.
You would have more output
at a given price level.
You could also think at
a given output level,
you would have a lower price level,
at a given price level.
Part two, long-run Phillips curve,
so that's this vertical
line right over here.
And the thing to appreciate
is the long-run Phillips curve
or the long-run aggregate supply curve,
these don't change unless
something structurally changes
in the economy, unless the economy changes
in some very fundamental way,
maybe a change in education
levels, change in population,
or change in technology.
And so here we would say
it just remains the same.
All right, we have more parts here.
Now let's go to part (c).
Identify a fiscal policy
action that could be used
to reduce the unemployment
rate in the short run.
So you have to be very careful here.
They're saying a fiscal policy action,
not a monetary policy.
If you said hey, we would
change the federal funds rate
or we would increase the money supply
or decrease the money supply,
those would be monetary actions.
We care about a fiscal policy action.
And this would be in
relation to lowering taxes
or raising taxes or increasing
or decreasing government spending.
Well, if we want to reduce
the unemployment rate,
one way to do the that would be
to shift aggregate demand to the right.
And one way to do that,
would be to put more money
in people's pockets,
and one way to do that,
is to have a tax cut.
Draw a correctly labeled
graph of aggregate demand
and short-run aggregate
supply, and show the impact
on the equilibrium
price level and real GDP
of the fiscal policy action
identified in part (c).
All right, let me draw that.
So this is going to be so that we have
our price level axis up here,
and we just drew something
very similar to this, real GDP.
And now let's draw our
short-run aggregate supply
which we have seen before.
That would be upward sloping,
as the price level increases
or the economy might be willing
to output more, so that's
short-run aggregate supply.
And then let's draw an
aggregate demand curve.
So let's call that AD sub one.
And then you have the equilibrium output,
let's call that Y sub one.
And you have your equilibrium
price level, PL sub one.
And now if you have a
tax cut, that would shift
aggregate demand to the right.
At any given price level,
people are gonna want more.
They're gonna demand more
'cause now they have more
money in their pockets,
and so it's going to shift to the right.
So I'll do a aggregate demand sub two.
And now we have a different
equilibrium real GDP,
so that is going to be Y sub two.
And it happens, and then we
have price level sub two.
So you see our price level goes up
and our aggregate output, our GDP,
our real GDP, goes up as well.
Based on the change in real
GDP identified in part (d),
will the supply of Country X's currency
in the foreign exchange market increase,
decrease, or remain the same, explain?
The way I think about it is if
you have real GDP increasing,
you're in a situation where you just have
more economic activity, the
national income has gone up.
And if national income has
gone up, people are gonna do
a lot more of everything
including buying imports.
And to buy imports, they would
have to increase the supply
of their currency in exchange markets
because they want to convert
it into foreign currencies
to buy those imports, and
so this will increase.
And we could say, because national income
has gone up,
people will buy more imports,
so the supply
of Country X's currency
for exchange will go up.
Currency X's currency
for exchange
will go up.
All right, part (f).
Based on your answer
to part (e) and assume
a flexible exchange rate system,
will Country X's currency
appreciate, depreciate,
or remain the same in the
foreign exchange market?
Well, if you hold all else equal,
but you increase the supply of something,
well, then the price of
it is going to go down.
If the demand for it stays constant,
but you increase the supply,
and that's what we just
talked about in part (e),
well, then the price is going to go down.
And if we're talking about
the price of a currency
and we say it's going
down, we would say that
that currency is depreciating,
so it would depreciate, and we're done.